we've bought some bends out to help you make your choice we've got the 240 litre bin the 140 litre and the 80 litre for your recycling most of you will already be using the 240 litre then this will continue to be collected fortnightly for your rubbish you can choose between 140 litre and the 80 litre bin and you can also choose to stick with the WDC rubbish bags which take about 50 to 60 litres of rubbish rubbish will be collected fortnightly for your organics you can choose all three bin sizes either the 240 litre the 140 litre or the 80 liter organics will be collected weekly if you've got more questions check out our Q&A s at Waunakee dear eGov TMZ ford / your choice or comment below